you've had this movie that you made the
comeback trail yes sir and because of
kovid it keeps
it got pushed to next year
as a lot of movies have yeah this is a
very big
project for you because you got to work
with
one of your all-time heroes i think a
lot of people's all-time hero robert de
niro yeah
conan this is what this is how covid
extra um
effed me up is that i had one of the
biggest breaks of my life
in that i got cast as a lead with robert
de niro in a giant comedy
directed and written by george gallo who
made midnight run one of my favorites
yep and i didn't even audition they
offered it to me i was like
but wait a minute it's a big part like
i'm on every page
and they were like yeah the deniro and
george want you for it
so i go down there we shoot it in
albuquerque i'm
it's literally me and de niro in every
scene we play
fantastic yeah movie producers who uh
who
are just the worst movie producers and
um
and and then covet hits and now it's not
coming out until next year it'll come
out but i was so excited
i mean this is just a still from the
movie but this is you
in bed with robert de niro and it's like
it's clear that you guys have
i mean there's no way you didn't get
intimately close with this man you
became very close and i had to i would
i would i'm not exaggerating that i
would because i love him so much and i
would go in
in my trailer in the mirror i would give
myself pep talks i would be like
you need to go into this scene because
i'd have scenes where i'm screaming at
him i'm like slapping him across the
face
and we're like and i would just give
myself a pep talk like this is just a
normal actor
this is not the most legendary hero that
you have
right right and so because i knew that
if i if i was intimidated i would suck
so i had to like
every scene i would give myself this
like mental like you got this
and that worked out yeah it was great
you know he's very shy
a lot of people don't know this about
him but he's but you know when he's not
in character
they call cut and he's kind of like you
know a quiet guy he goes back
to his chair and they go okay bob
already and he comes to set and he's
kind of quiet
and then they yell action and he goes
full amazing de niro but he's pretty
soft-spoken
but little by little we became um we
became closer and i made it to texting
status which was
thrilling we just texted another day you
text now with robert de niro
bobby d our text buddies sometimes he
calls me out of the blue because i
you know when you get like um you know
when you get um
a no caller id and you're like i'm not
gonna answer that who the hell could
that be
right now i know that it potentially is
bob de niro so now i always answer it
of course nine times out of ten it's a
cold caller but one out of ten times
conan
it's bob just saying hi do you have a
special voice cause sometimes i pick up
the phone
when it says no caller id i take a
chance but i don't use my voice
yes yeah the tough guy voice it's like
yeah
what hello i do uh crazy over-the-top
italian guy
or whether you want them from me and
uh eddie murphy bit in um i'm sorry i
have a horrible eddie murphy impression
but when he
on the on snl when he'd go this is how
you answer the door in my neighborhood
who is it
not bad i think that that i don't think
that was a terrible eddie murphy
impression
well i just always laughed at that that
was that's what i channel when i when i
answer the note caller id
hello